you've seen how such ever death sets and
evaluation metric is like placing a
target somewhere for your team to aim at
but sometimes partway through a project
you might realize you put your target in
the wrong place in that case you should
move your target let's take a look at an
example let's say you built a CAD
classifier to try to find lots of
pictures of cats to show to your can't
loving users and the message if you
decide to use is classification error so
Avram's a and B have respectively three
percent error and five percent error so
it seems like Gotham a is doing better
but let's say you try out these
algorithms you look at these algorithms
and album a for some reason is letting
through a lot of pornographic images so
if you ship algorithm a the users would
see more cat images because you know see
percent error is identifying cats but it
also shows you users some holographic
images which is totally unacceptable but
for your company as well as for your
users and in contrast album B as five
percent error so it lists classifies
fewer images but it doesn't have
pornographic images so from your
company's point of view as well as from
a user acceptance point of view album B
is actually much better algorithm
because you know it's not learning
through any common graphics images so
what's happened in this example is that
album a is doing better on the
evaluation metric is giving three
percent error but is actually worse
algorithm so in this case the evaluation
metric plus the DEF set it prefers album
a because the same look around a has
lower error which is the metric is using
when you're you and your users prefer a
ver and B because it's not learning
through Paulo graphics images so when
this happens when your evaluation metric
is no longer correctly rank ordering
preferences between algorithms in this
case is miss predicting that album a is
a better algorithm then there's a sign
that you should change your evaluation
metric or perhaps you're on development
sets or test set
so in this case Dimas classification
error metric that you're using can be
written as follows as 1 over M a number
of examples in your development set of
sum from I equals 1 to M and depth
number of examples of development set of
indicator whether or not the prediction
example I a development set is not equal
to the actual label I wear this is
useless notation to denote about their
predictive value right so either 0 and
this indicator function notation counts
up the number of examples on which you
know this thing in sign is true so this
formula just counts up the number of
misclassifying examples so the problem
with this evaluation metric is that they
trees pornographic and non pornographic
images equally but you really want to
conspire to not miss label pornographic
images like maybe recognize a
pornographic images academician
therefore show it to a unsuspecting
users therefore very unhappy with you
know unexpectedly seeing porn
so one way to change this evaluation
metric would be if you had a weight term
here and we call this WI where WI is
going to be equal to 1 in front X I is
non porn and maybe 10 or maybe even
larger number like 100 if X I is porn
so this way you're giving a much larger
weight to examples that are pornographic
so that the error term goes up much more
on the algorithm this makes mistakes on
classifying appalling graphics images a
cat image and in this example you're
giving a 10 times bigger wings to
classifying
on the graphic images correctly and if
you want this normalization constant it
will be right technically this becomes
sum over I of WI so then this error
would still be between 0 on 1 so the
details of this weighting aren't
important and actually influences
waiting you need to actually go through
your def in 10 sets to label the poly
graphic images in your def and test sets
you can implement this weighting
function but a high level takeaway is if
you find that you valuation metric is
not giving the correct rank order
preference for what is actually better
algorithm then that's a time to think
about defining a new evaluation metric
that you know and this is just one
possible way that you could define an
evaluation metric and the goal of the
evaluation metric is to accurately tell
you give in to class size which one is
better for your application for the
purpose of this video don't worry too
much about the details of how we define
a new error metric the point is that if
you're not satisfied with your own error
metric then don't keep coasting with an
error metric you're unsatisfied with is
that try to define a new one that you
think better captures your preferences
in terms of what's actually a better
algorithm one thing you might notice is
that so far we've only talked about how
to define a metric to evaluate
classifiers that is what defines an
evaluation metric that helps us better
rank all their classifiers when they are
performing at varying levels in terms of
streaming out porn and this is actually
an example of a full realization where I
think you should take a machine learning
problem and break it into distinct steps
so one knob or one step is to figure out
how to define a metric they captures
what you want to do and I will
is separately about how to actually do
well on this metric so I think of the
machine learning tasks as two distinct
steps to use the target analogy the
first step is to place the target so
define where you want to aim and then
it's a completely separate step so this
is one knife you could tune which is how
do you place the target and it's
completely separate problem think of it
as a separate knob to tune in terms of
how to do well at a target or how to you
know aim accurately or how to shoot at
the target and so defining a metric is
step one and you do something else for
step two so in terms of shooting the
target maybe your learning algorithm is
optimizing some cost function that looks
like this
are you minimizing this you know some
losses on your training set so one thing
you could do is to also modify this in
order to incorporate these weights and
maybe you end up changing this
normalization constant as well suggest
one over sum of WI between the details
of how you define J is important but the
point was with the philosophy for
formalization think of placing the
target that's one step and aiming and
shooting the target as a distinct step
which you do separately so so in other
words I encourage you to think of
defining the metrics as one step and
then you can and only after you've
defined in metric figure out how to do
well on that metric which might be
changing the cost function J that your
network is optimizing but for going on
let's look at just one more example
let's say that you're two cat
classifiers a and B have respectively 3
percent error and 5 percent error as
evaluated on your death set or maybe
even on your test set which are images
downloaded off the internet so high
quality well frame images but maybe we
need to tour your album a product you
find that averin B actually looks like
it's performing better even though it's
doing better or your death set
and you find that you've been training
off very nice high quality images
download without the internet but when
you deploy this on a mobile app users
are uploading all sorts of pictures much
less trained you're going public the
Catholic has twenty fish expressions
maybe images are much blurrier and when
you test out your algorithms you find
that a from B is actually doing better
so this would be another example of your
metrics and depth test set falling down
and the problem is that you're
evaluating on a different test set a
very nice high resolution well fairing
images but what your users really care
about is the album doing well on images
they're uploading which are maybe less
professional shots and blurrier and less
wall frames so the guideline is they're
doing well on your metrics and your
current deficit or different test sets
distribution if that does not correspond
to doing well on the application you
actually care about then change your
metrics and/or your depth test set so in
other words you can discover that your
dev test set has these very high quality
images but evaluating on this dev test
set is not predictive of how well your
app actually performs because you asked
me to view of lower quality images then
that's a good time to change your dev
test set so that your data better
reflects the type of data you actually
need to do well on but your vote
guideline is really if your current
metrics and data and your validating on
doesn't correspond to do well and what
you actually care about and change your
metric and/or your depth test set submit
to capture what you need the album to
actually do well on having the
evaluation metrics and the death set
allows you to much more quickly make
decisions about this album a or ever be
better so it really speeds up how
quickly you or your team can iterate so
my recommendation is even if you can't
define the perfect evaluation metric and
DEF set just set something up quickly
and use that to drive the speed of your
team iterating and then later down the
line you find out that it wasn't a good
one you're a better idea change it at
that time it's perfectly okay but what I
recommend it
so most teams is to run for too long
without an evaluation metric and depth
set because that can slow down the
efficiency or who should team can
iterate and improve your algorithm so
that's it on when to change your
evaluation measures and/or depth and
test sets
hope that these guidelines help you
serve your whole team to have a
well-defined target you can iterate
efficiently towards improving
performance on